[Music]
tonight
on Brian Ross investigates with its set
of the art aircraft and impressive naval
fleets the US will spend six hundred
eighty six billion dollars this year on
the military but this week the Pentagon
admitted it can't stop a simple drone of
the kind that attacked the Saudi Arabia
Aramco oil complex we look at areas
where the NATO alliance and NATO
capabilities are not at the level that
we would like them to be given the
threats that we now face from unmanned
aerial systems so what does that mean
here at home for sports arenas
government centers symbolic American
landmarks are we safe from the drones
plus meet the two women lawyers who say
the me2 movement has gone too far
especially on college campuses where
first and foremost two females in a
me-too world representing mostly males
accused of sex issues lawyers on the
other side say that's nonsense there's
anything that is going too far
and our shout outs with the approach of
another dangerous wildfire season in
California the reporter who first
documented how the big utility PG&E
was at fault for some of the most
devastating fires from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates and good evening and
welcome we begin tonight with a
startling admission for the Pentagon
this week that the u.s. does not really
have the ability to stop what has
emerged as a serious threat to American
security both at home and abroad no
country has a stronger or smarter
military the u.s. budget for defense now
stands at 686 billion dollars a year but
for all that money and smarts nothing
the US has was able to stop an attack by
18 drones on the Saudi Arabian Aramco
oil complex
supposedly protected by u.s. Patriot
anti-aircraft missiles
officials say each of the 18 drones
struck their targets with surprising
precision and a top Pentagon official
this week John Roode acknowledged the
problem we look at areas where the NATO
alliance and NATO capabilities are not
at the level that we would like them to
be given the threats that we now face
from unmanned aerial systems from cruise
missiles and from ballistic missiles we
do need to focus more on that but the
implications go far beyond the Middle
East
last year in Venezuela there was a
failed assassination effort against the
president authorities there say there
were two drones packed with explosives
which failed to hit their intended
target
but US law enforcement has increasingly
become concerned about the same thing
happening here about terrorists using
drones to attack American targets sports
arenas government centers American
symbolic landmarks now let me show you a
few of the features here so you'll
understand why I say this is truly a
weapon of the future YouTube is now full
of videos advertising new killing
capabilities for the off-the-shelf drone
stake them out and now a number of
defense companies are competing to
produce anti-drone shoot-down systems in
a rush to patch up what is now realized
as a gaping vulnerability we're joined
now by two people who have great
knowledge and insight on this issue
Ian Williams a security fellow and
deputy director of the missile defense
project at the Center for Strategic and
International Studies in Washington and
Karen Greenberg director of the Center
on national security at Fordham law
school here in New York
mr. Williams let me start with you what
happened in Saudi Arabia that the u.s.
Patriot anti-missile systems were unable
to stop those drones well the chief
challenge that they encountered was that
these drums and cruise missiles fly so
low that because of the curve of the
earth the radars of the patriot systems
can't pick them up until they're almost
on top of them another problem is is a
Patriots radar
only has a 120 degree view and we
believe that the radars that were at a
table cake at the Saudi oil facility
were pointed southward this makes a lot
of sense because Saudi Arabia has been
engaged in a air and missile defense
battle with Houthis in Yemen and with
missiles flying at them from the south
so it makes sense they would have an
oriented that way but when you have
threats then now coming in from the
north they they essentially came in from
through their backdoor so they can't see
behind them essentially that's correct
well Karen Greenberg what are the
implications here in the US for drones
now the ones in Saudi Arabia were more
sophisticated than the off-the-shelf
drones but it is a concern here isn't it
for US law enforcement well I think so
and I think it's being taken very
seriously first of all some of the
defensive systems that they had in place
in Saudi were provided by the u.s.
Patriot 2 I think I think there's also a
sense that we've entered a new form of
warfare which we noticed coming for a
long time it's almost like guerrilla
warfare with unarmed drones and so it's
a question of yes the technical part of
this is very important in terms of
having 360 capability being able to pick
things up and censor them but it's more
of a sign of what it really means to be
in this in this new era of warfare and
how good can we make not just our
offensive systems but our defensive
systems and I think a lot of thought is
gonna go into that now Karen a question
for you from our control room from the
executive producer Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda
what about here in the United States
we're obviously vulnerable to the same
kind of attacks what kind of defenses do
we have what if somebody threw those
drones up over a football stadium or
even over the White House yeah well
that's one of those very unsettling
questions and I don't think we have all
the answers to what we do have we do
have some defensive systems the question
is where are they where they've been
employed how how are we thinking about
just the kinds of things that Anne was
raising about how low they fly and
whether we can
pick them up but we definitely have been
evolving a system for that the problem
now is how many countries have drones it
used to be a handful it used to be
something that the Americans were on the
frontlines up now there are over 90
countries and we don't know the exact
number that have unmanned drones and so
the question really becomes can we put
the time and energy and resources into
what we need to do to create the right
defenses for this and it's it's a matter
of focus and resource so Ian on that
question we're talking really about
asymmetrical warfare here what's being
done to create a defense against these
drones well here in the United States
the only area that I know of that has
what I would call a robust sort of air
defense system is the National Capital
Region around around Washington DC there
is a it there is a very heavily
restricted airspace where if you enter
any any aircraft or anything down all
the way down to a small drone has to be
registered it has to be squawking
certain codes to to be authorized and
have an authorized registered flight
plan if you don't have that you will if
you're flying at jet speeds you will be
intercepted by an f-15 fighter jet if
you are flying a drone or a Cessna or a
smaller slower aircraft flying lower
you'll be intercepted by one of a very
small handful of Coast Guard helicopters
that's primary mission is to identify
what is it right is it a threat do we
need to be worried about it and then
report that back to to NORTHCOM and
NORAD in in Colorado who'll then make a
decision on what to do about it but
that's it kind of goes to one of the
chief challenges of these these threats
of these of these drones and small small
aircraft is you pick them up on radar
they can be easily confused with a bird
or or another kind of object and then
you don't really know what it is until
you actually see it with your own eyes
no doubt a serious problem thank you
both Ian Williams and Karin Greenberg
for joining us tonight you've opened a
lot of eyes whether you're in
sites into this troubling issue next up
as the me2 movement gone too far the
story of this college football player
and the female lawyers who took his case
when we return
the me2 movement has hit every aspect of
American society government finance law
the media and entertainment just this
week
famed tenor plácido Domingo was forced
to step away from a scheduled appearance
at New York's Metropolitan Opera after
allegations by a number of women of
sexual harassment he strongly denies the
allegations adding I'm concerned about a
climate in which people are condemned
without due process and you're about to
meet two lawyers women who agree saying
the me2 movement has gone too far
sometimes they say creating a mob
mentality especially on college campuses
the football team the Penguins are the
pride of Youngstown University big Malik
Richmond is senior but there was outrage
when word spreads that a star of the
football team's number 12
Malik Richmond had been convicted of
rape as a juvenile several years earlier
two high school football stars accused
of sexual assault was exploding on the
Internet and dividing people in
Steubenville Ohio the trial received
national attention Richmond and another
member of his high school football team
in Steubenville Ohio were found guilty
of raping a teenage girl during a
drunken party with the evidence
including a damning videotape of other
students boasting of what happened but
after serving a year in prison
Richmond enrolled at Youngstown
University and the coach had no problem
adding him to the football team I think
he'd earned that over not only what he
did with us but what he would he'd
endured over the last four or five years
but thousands of students signed
petitions to remove Richmond from the
team far greater numbers than those who
supported him there also is another
petition out saying a second
for Malik that is only at a hundred and
nineteen signatures and that other
signature petition is at seven thousand
signatures the school gave in kicking
Richmond off the team so he fought back
hiring two lawyers from Cleveland to go
to court and defend him from what they
called a mob mentality I think that was
a case that really highlighted the
danger and the challenges attendant to
mob mentality
Christina Zoopla and Susan stone have
taken on what is for many a very
unpopular set of clients where first and
foremost two females in a me-too world
representing mostly males accused of sex
issues and they won in court in
Youngstown arguing the school was wrong
to apply federal law called title nine
which they said did not cover a case
that occurred before a student was at
the University he was a good student
there were absolutely no conduct
violations this young student is a
wonderful human being who's really
learned from his experience and did not
deserve to be punished twice but it took
going to court yes going to court and
now that's what they're doing around the
country fighting back against schools
they say often don't know what they're
doing as they try to deal with
allegations of sexual abuse and assault
they become many courts Brian and I mean
we have called a lot of them kangaroo
courts because let's be fair these are
people who make up college body the
faculty the administration even the IT
person can take part in the
investigation and the adjudication of
the process for example they took the
College of Charleston to court to defend
a student who had been cleared by law
enforcement but will still be
investigated of sexual assault by the
college authorities I think no school
wants to be viewed as not taking sexual
assault seriously and so colleges and
universities are again wrestling with
this tension between fairness but also
taking a strong position
to address what is the scourge the issue
was highlighted during the Supreme Court
confirmation hearings for Brett
Kavanaugh accused of sexual assault when
he was an undergrad at Yale allegations
he strongly denied well if the same
thing happened today at Yale Yale
probably would issue an investigation
commenced an investigation into justice
Cavanaugh and he would be facing not
only just an investigation but a
suspension or potential expulsion from
school or worse schools issue no contact
orders and investigation unfolds it's
not unusual at all for students who have
been accused before an investigation has
even begun to be asked to move out of a
dorm to have their class schedule
juggled and in reorganized to avoid
running into an accuser at a certain
point on campus so just as Cavanaugh's
life would essentially be ruined even
before an investigation would be
commenced yet the issue of sex assaults
on campuses including rape is clearly a
scourge that has not been addressed
fully one recent survey found that one
in five female students in their fourth
year of college had experienced
attempted or completed sexual assault
while in college and while 65% of
surveyed rape victims reported what
happened to their friends or family less
than 10 percent reported it to police or
school officials but these two lawyers
say the pendulum has now swing too far
with a lack of fairness and due process
and a number of unintended consequences
we've wrestled with students calling r
us saying that they're so depressed and
again that comes back to that approach
of treating our students with compassion
and care you've had clients who are
suicidal yeah absolutely many because
because they've lost their friends
they're kicked out of their fraternity
they're kicked out of their sports teams
nobody wants to talk to them nobody
wants to study with them and they feel
such shame after the allegation and such
loneliness and so it's despair that they
can't see
yonder better future a title nine
finding on a student's record is really
the modern-day scarlet letter to get a
different perspective on this I talked
this week with one of the lawyers who's
been a leader in helping women stand up
to men who they say have abused them
Jeannie Harrison has her own former Los
Angeles and I asked her if she thought
me too had gone too far if there was in
fact a mob mentality I don't see that at
all in fact in my practice I find that
it is exceptionally difficult for
victims to come forward and report they
are terrified about the consequences and
many of them even when I meet with them
and offer a tremendous amount of support
which is a core function of my office is
offering that support to victims and
survivors they even still decide that
they're not going to come forward and
report there are many people who don't
come forward to report because it's just
too scary so I don't think it's a mob
mentality I don't think there's anything
that has gone too far
victims have always been accused of
making accusations or reporting
incidents that the defendant or the
accused say never happened it's it's the
same song a little bit of a different
tune can both be true though can there
be cases where men are essentially what
they say railroaded or falsely accused I
mean there are people who make false
claims but that's part of the system
that's the system is set up to handle
that to test the claims and for victims
to have to testify and put up evidence
which includes their testimony about
what happened and the system is
configured so that they're gonna be
credibility determinations that are made
by the Trier of fact whether that is in
you know school sex abuse cases or
office and work sexual harassment cases
that's the purpose of the system so when
these two lawyers who represent
primarily men on campuses say they have
sympathy for these men they are
ostracized often some of them they say
have actually been suicidal because of
the allegations is there a problem with
the process on college campuses no I
don't think there's a problem with the
press
on college campuses I think that what
does happen there are some cases
obviously on an individualized basis
that seemed not to be warranted we're
certain you know alleged conduct doesn't
seem to have occurred and there is no
doubt that those who are accused of
conduct in which they did not engage
suffer as a result but there are many
people who actually have engaged in
really inappropriate conduct including
sexual abuse and take things way too far
and really you know inflict tremendous
tremendous emotional suffering on women
and men whom they attack and their lives
are changed forever and so I I think
it's regrettable when people choose to
make false accusations but I think that
we cannot allow the backlash which was
almost instantaneous when the me to
movement began we cannot allow the
backlash to drive further drive away the
victims who really do need to come
forward and report these incidents
Jeannie Harrison thank you so much for
joining us appreciate your insights
thank you so much up next our shoutout
as the peak of the California wildfire
season approaches the reporter who first
documented who was to blame for many of
those dangerous wildfires
with the approach now of the peak
wildfire season in California a shout
out for the reporter there who first
documented the state's big Power Company
PG&E was often at fault and he continues
to follow the story since we first
highlighted his work just last year in
2018 there was the state's deadliest and
most destructive fire the camp fire
reporter Matthias Gaffney known as T in
the newsroom was determined to find out
the story of what happened using a
database that archives police and fire
frequencies and I just started listening
right around the time that they believe
the fire started and sure enough I heard
that
dispatcher get a call there's a possible
power light hazard and they basically
reported that there were wires down
underneath transmission lines and this
is right at the moment that the camp
fires believed was started and right in
the area that the camp fire was believed
to have started running right down so
that was a real big break in finding out
what may be the cause for this fire the
evidence pointing to the state giant
PG&E utility tge just now I said that
they are probably at fault with their
equipment having a malfunction and so
that was you know just a few days after
the camp fire that we were able to
narrow that down and show that PG&E very
well could be at fault and beyond the
equipment malfunction Gaffney determined
that PG&E if it followed its own
guidelines should have shut down the
power in such high risk fire conditions
most of those criteria were actually met
prior to the camp fire yet for some
reason they decided to keep the power on
PG&E now has declared
bankruptcy saying it expects to face
massive lawsuits I'm born and raised in
the Bay Area here and I have a you know
family I find it really impactful to
kind of do reporting that immediately
impacts my community and you know the
people I've grown up with and I love and
and respect so it's really pretty
rewarding so a second shout out to
Matthias Gaffney who was a finalist for
a Pulitzer Prize since we first
highlighted his work now with the San
Francisco Chronicle
he continues to track PG&E reporting
this week on what was a third round of
power cut offs by the Power Company in
hopes of another devastating fire season
being avoided that's our program for
tonight thanks so much for joining us
we'll see you back here next week
you